this will be a different theme it won't
be uh what is java now this time
but we on our panel on wednesday it
became basically
a quiz show for chaba i just asked him
anything you could think of
it was very it was it was awesome but
we'll have a different theme this time
um but uh so how should we how much
should we start
emma um i think maybe if we could first
just have all the panelists um
uh turn up oh great i think we have
everybody now which is awesome
um uh turn on that thing and then um
people should feel free to ask questions
via the
um uh uh you know just live if they
would like to um but also we
collected some questions in advance so
that we could kick this off
um uh mimi so maybe we'll start because
um
we so you didn't get a chance to have
too many questions at the end and so
maybe we all start asking him
um the first one which is sort of a high
level one to kick off and
um and i guess maybe before we start the
panel this is our just as a reminder
this is the last part of our workshop
and
i really appreciate all the speakers
being part of this and the attendees
it's been fantastic
um and being part of this with sean and
mendy has been great
who've really done an enormous amount of
work to make this happen so
thank you everybody um and for those of
you who are going to nurbs next week of
course there's additional
work on this topic that will be coming
out next week and then also additional
discussions at the workshop
um i think one of the first questions
that at a high level that maybe sergey
you could start with and then anybody
else could chime in which is
um i think it's a really exciting time
right now to be thinking about
batch and offline reinforcement learning
and so i'm curious what you think will
be possible
in five years that isn't now um i think
reinforcement learning is not used
commonly
right now in industry um not in the
online case not in the offline case
but i think that could be changing very
soon and so maybe sergey you could kick
us off and think what
you know what sort of be the results or
what type of applications
or usage of batch and offline rl might
be possible in five years
yeah um so well there's two parts to
this
answer for me there's the things that i
personally am excited about and then
there's this thing the things that i'm
excited about
for the field so to speak so you know i
personally i work on robotics i'm really
keen on the prospect of robots doing
cool stuff in the real world and i think
that
uh using data and large models will
enable robots to generalize meaningfully
so you could have robots that actually
do
you know useful things not just in
factories but in kind of everyday
environments
that said i think there's also a bigger
picture here which is
about decision making methods that can
address problems
that are very difficult to currently
address with automated
decision-making techniques and these are
and i think that this is
we might actually see a lot of impact in
this area things like
uh you know problems that are that are a
little bit bigger than where you could
hope to do exploration you know
imagine not just not just medical
treatment plans but things like you know
determining the tax policy and interest
rates for major
uh uh nation states right you know
things that things that are that are on
a scale where
there's definitely data that uh it's
definitely really important
but you know you're not gonna do online
exploration for setting you know u.s
tax policy for example uh and i actually
think that there is potential for that
to be really impactful because you know
that's a domain where uh
you know this the stakes are really high
but there's also a lot of value and
there's also human oversight like you
know it's not like
you're going to have an algorithm in
real time changing the tax code
it's going to make proposals people are
going to look at those proposals and
then accept or reject them and i can
actually see that happening
and that could work out really well
i think that would be really exciting it
certainly brings in something that i
think people
you know just maybe been a little
special this week but not too much yet
which is how do we better combine humans
with these types of suggestions from the
automated rl and i think that's going to
be a really important question going
forward
um stefan do you want to add to that of
things that you see maybe from kind of
like
coming up from a sort of a business
school perspective or others that you
think where
um i tend to think of econometrics it's
more focusing on the one-time step
setting um as opposed to
the sequential but of course you can
correct me um but where do you think
applications might be happening that we
don't see yet
that might be there in five years
thanks uh that's a very good question
and i i guess
i i understand his point about trying to
optimize that optimize the tax code i
think that's a very
interesting example to think about i
apologize if it was a very naive comment
that i i know nothing about the survey
i mean i i i don't either i'm a
statistician not an economist
but i think what's one thing i think is
very interesting about that
is that kind of if we did want to think
about optimizing the tax code
like most methods and
rl assume that if you have agents you
kind of
understand a lot of what the agents are
doing and you can
simulate them or get very close to
simulating them or something like that
whereas kind of if you're thinking about
optimizing the tax code
it's clear that there are people people
make choices for
reasons that kind of realistically we
have no hope of
modeling we can maybe have some general
principles of like
people generally like having more money
than less money
but and and different people might be
more or less sensitive to kind of
how much money they have but beyond that
it seems hard to kind of model people in
detail
so i think in that kind of application
we're going to need to have
methods for rl that kind of are
able to work even if you just have a
very high level understanding of how the
agents are being
uh but can't actually simulate agents
but it seems like
kind of for the academic community
that there are a lot of challenges still
on top of wouldn't be able to get there
would any of the other panelists or
other speakers from the week like to
comment on this issue
all right so maybe we can talk next
about um sort of i think one of the
other focuses of this week has been
thinking about these very different
types of communities that have been
coming together
um uh to think about or maybe not coming
together yet but have been thinking
about very related questions over the
last few years
um one of the questions that shawn
brought up was to say you know
how does control theory practice to
differ from sort of control
um and rl theory sean maybe you can ask
the question to clarify if anybody has
yeah well yes i'm just thinking how
i mean actually can my control friends
out there
moonzer have me harlow tell me if i'm
wrong but a lot of practitioners have
almost given up
on i mean almost npc is almost all you
use in some areas
of course every every area has a
different point of view every every
industry is a different point of view
but this sort of um
you know the mdp sort of view it you
know which is a favorite
approach in rl it's almost been thrown
away it seems like
in the control community practice
and uh and it suggests maybe
maybe rl should go and look at what's
been successful in the control community
and maybe try to rethink uh rl
approaches based on what's been
successful i don't know
but um you know it's awfully barred
question right now i can jump in a
little bit
you know follow up on chance this is mr
daley from mit
so um so um
i think one of the interesting thing
about control theory that it focused
on safety critical missions and
as a result the type of guarantees that
were needed were very difficult to do
from real time sort of
adaptation so to speak right so you know
the failure of that of control in the
70s came from the fact that you know
we wanted to apply that to fighter
aircraft and
and they crashed and the
the fundamental problem there was the
modern specification
you know so you know you kind of assume
a class of models and then you have
uncertainty and that certainty kicks in
then the control system goes
haywire um and control
was driven a lot by safety critical
systems you know aerospace was a huge
player in the development of control
theory uh
i think that robotics in the sense of
maybe a vacuum cleaner is a little
different than say sending a robot to
kind of uh remove a landmine you know um
and so i think that those are the types
of application that
i think but sean is right i think you
know there's a lot of frustration by the
control community
to to sort of provide guarantees systems
work but then they don't work all the
time and we want them to work
you know with an error of 10 to the
minus 9 which was really hard
so that's one aspect of adaptation
control theory that kind of shied away
from
reinforcement learning um or adaptation
in general now reinforcement learning is
about simulation but then the absolute
you know the other
i would say the other aspect we sort of
um struggled with a little bit is that
for these types of systems we have the
only experimentation we can do
isn't what we call a closed loop system
you know
system you know if you want to
experiment with an airplane the airplane
is flying you already have a control
system
because otherwise it won't be flying you
know and so and so you're experimenting
with
something already controlled and you're
trying to figure out
how to improve the control system right
so you're connected you're so you don't
have a
the simulator can be a dynamical system
on the side but if you wanted to take
real data
you're sort of contr you know limited by
the class of
inputs and the class of signals that you
can try which is
which is a little bit of a of an issue
having said
that i think that that actually brings
up a huge opportunity for looking into
two types of problems one
how if you collected data from an
existing control
system so the system is actually closed
loop and functioning
how do you apply reinforcement learning
to come up with a better strategy for
that systems and i think that that's a
that's a really nice problem to think
about and the other one is that what if
we figured out a way to relax the
stability sort of the safety aspect of
the problem
to maybe potentially a kind of a higher
margin of probabilistic safety
could we actually get away with some of
the technologies that
control theory have and translated to
reinforcement learning there's a lot of
dynamical system understanding in
control theory that could
be you know sort of transferred into the
understanding of some of the algorithmic
issues of reinforcement learning
so those are my two cents about control
and rl
[Music]
yeah if i if i can chime in as well i i
couldn't agree more
with with mozart i think robustness is
at the heart of what every control
practitioner does and aerospace
engineering is
one area where you know two
tools from robust control theory
are being used actually uh at least in
some
some aerospace applications and uh
also it is a domain where there are well
established practices in terms of how to
provide safety
guarantees because simply you you don't
have legal room and
as we as we start bringing some of these
techniques from
rl to safety critical application cell
driving for example
i feel that it is instructive actually
to take a look at these success stories
and to see what kind of lessons we can
learn richard murray gave last year a
fascinating talk at the
ipam workshop at ucla and
to to me it was an eye-opening
experience in terms of
the length to which aerospace engineers
go in terms of guaranteeing
performance requirements that aircraft
have have to
to meet and obviously there are
tremendous expectations from uh
you know control systems that we are
going to put to self-driving cars
perhaps even bigger
than than we have in uh aerospace and
at the same time you know you you you
you need to keep in mind that
you don't have a luxury of uh
you know spending as much resources as
you do in aerospace engineering so how
to meet these stringent requirements and
making it economically
feasible and you know checking all boxes
i think
is is a huge challenge but robustness is
at the heart of many
many things that you know uh
made the difference in in control
community
i'm seeing similar trends happening
today in reinforcement learning to what
control community was obsessing back in
in 70s perhaps because before bus
control
enter into into the mainstream
and sorted out many of the issues that
standard of
optimal control techniques couldn't
handle because of the uncertainty in the
in the system and bringing some of these
tools
from controls community and seeing
actually how how they're going to
play along with the techniques that
reinforcement learning community
is developing is is an important
challenge another thing that is
also important and i don't think that
many people in the enforcement learning
community are paying attention to our
fundamental limitations in terms of
what you can achieve with feedback
sometimes i get an impression that
you know anything is achievable and
everybody who has ever designed
controller for for dynamical systems
knows that in in the presence of output
feedback you have
fundamental limitations in terms of
performance
that you can accomplish and if you if
you don't pay attention to these
fundamental limitations you're bound to
to to failing so some of these things uh
are going to enter soon rather than
later into into
the mix but it's surprising perhaps that
they still
haven't been thought carefully about
as much as they should maybe to push on
that a little bit like i think um
i it's clear that there's a number of
really wonderful ideas from
controls that might be relevant to rl
but what do you think are the open
questions
in our in controls right now and or the
places where rl might have insights that
could be helpful to controls
so just as an example and you guys can
correct me if i'm wrong my understanding
is things like finite sample complexity
has not been looked at as much
in the controls community like benrect
and others has have thought about that
recently but that's something that rl
has thought
a lot about of how do you design and do
sample efficient exploration
um and do things like cumulative regret
minimization during that process and
kind of even in the tabular setting that
was open until fairly recently like my
group and other groups
sort of that we have tight bounds for
that setting um and i don't know if
that's because in some of these settings
exploration is easier you know you can
kind of you don't necessarily have to
we think about often these are discrete
cases where exploration might be
quite hard to reach um but in general
you know and that question might be
naive and i'd love to hear your
perspectives of
uh either just in general where the the
controls field is
what are the open questions that people
are thinking about in that space and or
what insights from rl may or may not be
relevant to those
i have to comment on this quickly i
don't want to
monopolize the conversation but uh so on
one hand
um i think what um harley said is really
important and that is it's the apple
feedback problem it's not the state
feedback problem
that is actually a challenge and model
misspecification is a big challenge
so all of these sample complexity
results are by the way
if you look at the literature of
learning and identification for control
from 1990 to 2000
um there is sample complexity analysis
worst case analysis i think it was done
at that time but the problem is that you
know and i think i think that
the concentration of these types of
questions is important but
it's not that they have not been looked
at i think it's the problem of the
output feedback
with model misspecification that you
unless you embed a lot of information
about
the problem a priority um the control
problem is very hard
and and that's i think where we needed
to understand
are there data-driven bonds that can
allow us to then
update the the class of models we're
looking at
in real time so you know and that's
that's what's lacking that's where the
concentration of research right now
between what i would consider you know
statistical
uh statistical properties and control
theory right you're gonna have to figure
out a way in which you grow the model
class
and in such a way that you're still
maintaining stability i think again
that's the safety critical question
but then you're improving the
performance as it comes along so
um and if you assume that you don't know
anything and these bonds are not
you know then the sample complexity is
is exponential
and we've shown that results right from
the beginning that
that it would take you know even for a
finite impulse response learning problem
you have an exponential growth in the
and the experimentation that you have to
do
so there's a it's got to be a paradigm
shift right there's not you know
either a nicer parameterization of of a
classes or problems or
or really nice data driven bonds that
you can use
to run the real time control problem
something that maybe i'd like to add to
this as well and i i was
i was listening to mihaela's response
and that really kind of got me thinking
um i think there's there's a little bit
of a
of an issue with the assumptions that we
make in reinforcement learning that i
think
has a danger of creating a little bit of
a blind spot so in controls and
kind of robotics oftentimes the starting
point is there is a model
and that has certain limitations like
the model is not the correct model
but the the difference is that in
controls
we usually acknowledge that the model
might not be right which is why we worry
a lot about things like robustness
in reinforcement learning i think
there's a tendency to say well it's
model-free reinforcement learning like
who cares if we don't know the model
it's reinforcement
he's going to figure it out but in
reality
no matter how how we're doing the
reinforcement learning that model
specification or model mismatch thing
will actually happen in the real world
like you know even if you're using real
data
it's probably not going to be fully
represented everything you'll see
and while there is research on
robustness and reinforcement learning
too i think it's comparatively much more
much more niche and i think that you
know certainly for the kinds of problems
that control theorists worry about i
think
a lot more emphasis on that in rrl would
be important and i think it's just we
have a cultural bias and are able to
miss that because we're like oh we're
model free so the thing will just figure
it out
uh and i think we need to kind of get
over that if we want to
attack these problems and controls
awesome
[Music]
someone you want to add into that i've
been seeing you've been posting the chat
well i see java has some comments on
what is the new
yeah i i was just thinking a little bit
about this
[Music]
and and i think that this is all great
like we should
unite forces whatever uh whenever we can
uh and uh
only good things can come out of that uh
at the same time
if i look at the classical results i i
find it
a little bit challenging to imagine how
they
would apply to some of the problems that
people
seem to care about these data i think
that this goes where minter was uh
was uh kind of finishing his comment
that if you take
a perception action loop for example
uh output feedback control if you wish
it's so complex this relationship like
are you gonna invert it like how are you
going to invert it like what do you know
about these properties
we can write simulators for the s
but we can even write the equations that
cover in those simulators
but this is not the same thing as like
believing i did that this is going to be
the
true model uh some aspects in the
simulator are going to be off
others are going to be just fine uh
on one hand uh at the same time if if
you
uh take the robust approach and then you
would say that well
okay like what do i know about my thing
well it's complex so let's just model it
with
looseness then you would be so off right
so
very general non-parametric techniques
are not going to cut it so i feel that
there is a tension here
and i i think uh maybe one
uh positive thought regarding this is
uh which i tried to sell like two days
ago is that computers
are great they're strong uh
and we can rely more on what they can
compute
and that's kind of the the unique
feature of their
approach i'm not saying that uh you
should stop
all research that goes into clever
algorithms i will not stop that right
like i love theory and i want to do that
but
at the same time maybe the emphasis
should be shifted
towards new ways of thinking about how
to use computers
uh to compute solutions that uh that we
want to deploy
uh there maybe rely more heavily on
simulation based optimization what not
right
um so i don't know what what do you
think about this
but you're also talking about computers
for actually
testing right i mean you're talking
about you know
trying to efficiently at least probe for
robustness
with including that right
so whenever like
traditionally uh we like to think about
doing the work by sitting down and then
doing the calculations on paper
but that's kind of missing out a little
bit on
uh what's cool about in the new era that
the computers can do a lot of this
[Music]
and this doesn't necessarily mean that
uh
that you should stop doing theory of
course
not because uh now with these newer
bigger questions
uh there are new interesting three
questions arising
[Music]
yeah i think i think i i totally agree
with you i think
actually the reason why model predictive
control and adaptive model prediction
control has been very successful is
because it does exactly what you
described
you know it kind of like runs a
simulation
and it predicts the next few steps
and then corrects and re-adapts you know
and so you've got the simulation compute
computation running together
simulation and you do the complicated
all the optimization in a numerical in a
sort of a
simulation type so it does exactly what
you described and that's why
actually it works you know um it has
limitations as mahadas said sort of this
fundamental limits you can't do
everything within pc
but you can do a lot and you know
driving a lot of cars with mpc right an
adaptive mpc
so i totally agree with you i think a
better convergence between simulation
and estimation and learning or control
how do we integrate the simulation into
our control strategies in a systematic
way i think that's a really interesting
question
um you know people have tried to do that
for example with rare events
because you're trying to figure out
something really bad happening and so
you're running these parallel
simulations to kind of figure out if
something bad is going to happen and
then you sort of anticipate and
in fact i think sean maybe knows some of
that work and
the power grid right i mean people
independent system operators are always
running these types of models to try to
figure out if there's an artist that's
going to happen at any given time so
that they can actually
prevent it from happening beforehand and
outages are rare
uh the one other comment i wanted to
make is that where there is a
potential of an open problem is the
relationship between
uh in dynamical systems the relationship
between uh
model reduction and learning you know so
you know
in sort of in control theory there's
been a development of a lot of
techniques of how to come up with a
reduced model that approximates the
system in a strong sense in an input
output sense
right and they you know they involve
hankel matrices and they
you know sort of complicated
methodologies and so forth
and learning doesn't pay attention to
those methodologies learning goes
directly into either
parametric or non-parametric learning
and you're learning some
some underlying systems the question is
what's the relationship
are there closer relationships
particularly in a closed loop setting
between
the statistical learning theory and
actual model reduction techniques
so ask yourself the question for a given
finite data
can i learn the best k dimensional
approximation of the system
you know um can i go directly to learn
that system
uh without having a sympathetically
converged but for
infinite data point and even identifying
what their order is
would be important i guess i guess note
about that
is that sometimes the models themselves
are going to be just
way too complex right and there's so
many irrelevant details about the word
especially in this again perception
action loops
uh that you don't want to predict that
you don't want to model you don't want
to learn
so somehow i think that the real
challenge and that's like
interesting theoretical challenge as
well is to do this small
uh order reduction in such a way that
you keep
the parts that are important and you
throw away the parts that are not
important
and then how do you do this like how do
you organize this i think that's
that's really fascinating and maybe this
builds on i think one of the really
interesting points before which is i
think arl is starting to think about the
model miss specification
sure sure and um i know sharon manor is
also very interested in that and i think
some of the work that's been happening
in contextual bandits right now of kind
of model selection and trying to
to build on chavo's point trying to
figure out not what is the model that is
best predictor but what is the model
that allows you to achieve the best
performance
um and i think that that work is still
sort of focusing on the case of trying
to say
you know assuming you kind of have
infinite data like you're adapting these
but then
further saying if you can kind of have
almost like a real-time type approach
where like you're constantly adapting
the model
size as the data grows um you know i
think that sort of stuff could be really
exciting and maybe some of that stuff
already exists in controls but i think
our theoretical analysis that in in the
rls space and the bandit space is pretty
recent like just over the last year or
two
by the way um so just to to to
to turn things a little bit so we
stopped talking about the batch aspect
of the problem
that that you're given some data and i
think that uh
like i would be very interested in
hearing what people think about
uh for example what sergey was saying in
his talk that maybe you should just
reduce it to model based uh
optimization right uh is that is that
the way to go or should we do
something else like what what people
what do people think about this
well shaw i think you can definitely
reduce
uh off policy queue learning to model
based optimization but then you're
losing
a particular assumption right so in
model based optimization
a pre-order you don't make an assumption
on on conditional independencies in your
uh in your variables whereas in rl you
know that there are conditional
dependencies and they make the markov
property
so in principle you can get a lot more
mileage from exploiting that conditional
independence
property i i i was also thinking a
little bit more broadly about the
question
though right like yeah maybe maybe there
is some answer
uh to your particular setting that's
fine
uh but in general how to
think about this problem of like what
what are the
uh the interesting problems when it
comes to
learning to make decisions uh based on
data and you are in the sequential
uncertain setting i think that it's it's
uh it's really interesting to think
about this uh
uh like whether you can somehow
like the distribution robust
optimization is that the answer
pessimism is the answer like how do you
justify all of this like we had a bunch
of talks about this uh
even throughout the uh the program uh
or are there any other competing
approaches and
uh like how to go about uh the whole
thing
i do think that sometimes this is maybe
a very uh
high level vague thought sometimes in rl
we come up with very good ideas
uh but couch them in overly
uh detailed um problem settings like
you know maybe one point i was trying to
make in my talk
that i think i didn't make it
sufficiently explicit is we should ask
like you know
if you have something that works for a
bacheloreal problem does it also work
for
non-sequential problems does it work for
other problems and often the answer is
yes
uh so i feel like we could kind of make
more general statements in some of these
cases when we're working on rrl
there is a challenge with the
presentations there right like who is
your audience uh but
sure like i i totally agree like i think
that we often face this challenge of
that
the idea is emotional and then cut
across many different
areas and many different types of
problems
and what's the best way of presenting
now
[Music]
so what do other people think
[Music]
i mean the question is very generally
my reaction is kind of in in line with
okay like
again if you if you have these kind of
if you can use the full
kind of you're learning rl structure you
have
all these like little chunks of
information uh
maybe you have some trajectories where
you followed the actions you're
interested in for some amount of time
but not other parts of time
and you can still if you're willing to
kind of solve the full rl problem you
can
still extract information from these
trajectories
whereas you try to reduce everything to
a
more standard learning problem then it's
kind of very unclear how to reason about
this
um yeah something something i wish i had
a
better understanding of is i think i
think we
like methods like inverse propensity
weighting and everything
we all know that if we have kind of a
finite horizon problem and we start
on trajectory and then at some point
some trajectory kind of deviates from
the policy we want to evaluate then we
know how to use that
for learning and we know how to use that
for reasoning but what about
kind of trajectories where the actions
are on policy and then we go off policy
and then we come back on policy
um it seems like kind of outside of a
markovian setting
uh at least i i it seems like
there should be something useful to be
done there
but that isn't quite captured you know
so far
so there's a fundamental i i think i
maybe i'm
i'm getting what stefan is saying maybe
i'm i might have to rephrase something
it could be rephrasing could be
something completely different but
i think that there's a fundamental
question that i am struggling with and
we're working on it obviously and that
is
how do we actually do decisions from
data okay
so um you know so i think of a situation
i'm collecting data of a particular
process
and that process has been running for a
while and i'm just collecting this data
back in my mind i always think of it as
that airplane flying and i'm collecting
data from the plane flying you know
and now i get this data and i want to do
reinforcement learning where
reinforcement learning
requires me to figure out if i pick a
new policy
what the cost of that particular policy
is right
that need a simulator to tell me how do
i evaluate the process i don't have a
simulator
i have a bunch of data i collected this
data under some conditions
right they were running maybe there was
feedback now i pick a policy
i need to figure out what is the outcome
of that particular policy i need to go
to the data and figure out that
right and i think that that's a link
that actually is a
is an interesting theoretical question
how do i evaluate
the policy i picked the cost of the
policy i paid
from the leader that i connected that
potentially he could have been running
as a market system with the feedback and
so forth
and he has an interesting question once
i know how to evaluate the cost of my
policy i can do policy iteration i can
do it all
you know but then i need that yeah this
is the off policy evaluation problem
in rl the people like to call it like
that and then
there is this belief that you can
you can reduce off policy optimization
that the way we call it this battery
problem to all policy aviation by and
large and that's kind of like what uh
you're alluding to in your language
uh i'm not sure i'd buy that uh
it's it's not so simple right because uh
because of the variance bias like i
think but i think there's been some
interesting work over the last couple of
years thinking about that like
my group surveys group et cetera and
kind of i feel like 2020 has been a hard
year for many years and pessimism
and it's been interesting to see that a
lot of the work in the um so the off
policy rl perspective for optimization
has all centered around the idea of
pessimism and the sense of optimizing
for lower bounds
and trying to think explicitly about the
covariate shift the variance
and also trying to think more
conservatively about given the data
that's available how can we avoid
extrapolation error
right i agree but i think maybe this is
the point
that java may be trying to get at is if
you reduce
our policy optimization to have policy
evaluation then expressivity wise at
the minimum you need something like for
every policy pie
i have enough expressivity power to even
come up with a reasonable lower bound of
it
right whereas if you try to directly
solve the optimality equation
it seems like the the the you you may be
able to reduce
a lot of uh representation burden on
your function pass major
so i mean i've written some paper along
the lines of you know what emma you're
talking about like you know
optimizing lower bound for every single
policy and i do ope for all of them
but yeah i'm not convinced that's the i
think i'm half half on the on the best
and and kind of the same comment applies
to any other reductions right so
reducing to model-based optimization and
so so far
like uh and and it's i guess it's it's
like
it's just pushing the difficulty from
here to there and like it's not to say
that like any of these methods
would be invalid in a sense but maybe
there is some kind of uh ordering
between the strengths of the methods
that we don't know about yet
uh or maybe that is not but then like
that's an interesting theoretical
question to find out right
yeah so i think a high-level question i
i try to understand is do we need
a model on the system so for example
like in
as nun presented in his work so actually
in batch policy evaluation it's possible
to only
assume some representation for the q
function we might we might not
need some assumption about the
transition model but there are also
other settings in which we do need
assumption on the transition model or if
we have
we know that the system is from some
model then we can reduce the sample
complexity we can be more efficient
lucky and pc so i think there's a very
interesting
i was a very interesting gap between
like when
do we need to do system identification
and apparently if we can do system id
and system id has a long history and
control and there are a lot of ideas
that can be really explored yet
but there are also other settings maybe
model 3 methods are sufficient
so i thought it would be interesting to
really try to draw the line on like
what is needed and what do we need
system id and
how system id can really help
what are the respective strengths of
these methods
yeah i think just to follow up moser's
discussion i feel like if
i mean the the tools in control for
system id and model reduction
they can be extremely helpful and then
combined with
research and other computational tools
and to reduce
the the sample complexity for learning
but there are also
other scenarios in which we might want
to
try not to make strong assumptions on
the transition model so i think it will
be interesting to think about
one do we want to go for the model based
approach
and uh how how do we want to take the
maximum advantage from both worlds
yeah it may be important to make a
distinction between system
identification and model-based
reinforcement learning because
you know system identification at least
you know from from the world that i'm
familiar with refers to a setting where
uh you know you know there's a realized
realizability
assumption you know what your model
class is and generally you're trying to
identify
you know a fairly limited number of
parameters
at least from the problems i've seen in
robotics usually if you're
in that setting you kind of know how to
do that
uh and the the bits that provide a lot
of challenges are things like
you know where you have to deal with
perception uh issues that are
phenomenal they're really hard to model
and all of these are our settings where
the existing system id tools i think
will not actually be all that useful
you know put another way if you can do
system id there are many things that you
can do that will work well and
probably you know reinforcement learning
researchers are not needed for that
yeah by the controversial opinion i
guess so i think i'm referring to this
broader view of system id so i think
traditionally system id was about
we have a particular polynomial model
and then we try to estimate particular
parameters under the strong
realizability assumption but i think
there are also works in control theory
or in other
people in other related literature like
people try to find for example
the best low rank approximation or try
to find the best
oscillating state model as an
approximation to the true system
without knowing the actual uh
parametric parametric form of the model
so i i don't know whether that belongs
to
steel system id where that belongs to
model reduction
but i think like spiritually they are
along the same line
and it's about like maybe there's
something we can learn from that
perspective
i apologize i have to exit for another
meeting
i enjoyed the conversation thank you so
much for inviting me
thank you monster great thank you good
to see you
thank you mother thank you
[Music]
and we are a little bit of probably wrap
up in a second
um if anybody has a last favorite
topic that they have our favorite thing
that they think we should all work on
that they haven't had a chance to
mention maybe they could say that in a
sentence or two
um otherwise we can just wrap up
maybe just along the the same lines so i
think
uh in some settings at least in some
settings
what you will end up doing is learn from
data and put
you know what you know the controller
that you design on a real system
and it may not work right so you you go
you will have to do something you know
have a runtime monitor or something to
make it work on the real system so
there's an interplay between design of
that real-time monitor
and what you learn you know from the
data and
how do you do that i think there is you
know there is
there's an interesting question there
you know like maybe you know
uh some of the discussion was about uh
model reduction
so uh you know you it's not necessarily
the case that you know you
uh you try to find the
the the least you know model reduction
so to speak that you can find you know
it all so there is a
once you do that there is still a
question of okay you got to make this
work on the real system so you
you know you you will have to design
sort of uh
a controller a runtime controller so to
speak that will take care of you know
the issues that arise because
you know what you've done in the civil
you know what you've the design that
you've gotten by designing
uh via reinforcement learning or in the
simulator is not gonna work
so how do you do that i think that's uh
that's an intro
i think there's not really much uh on
that i mean uh
you know or what is the right
formulation for that
it sounds related to what we might talk
about as like sim to real but i think
you're talking about some sort of deeper
connections than that
i think there's sort of a lot of
different algorithmic approaches to that
happening in the robotics community
though
sergey and others would know more than
me but i imagine that there are very
different types of approaches to that
depending on the systems that are being
tried to be modeled
uh i think it's connected to the sim to
real problem but
at least i had something a little bit
more in mind you know when you have
you can have uh it's not just about
distribution shift it's about
uh uh you know some constraints that you
just cannot you know work with while
you're trying to use reinforcement
learning and doing design
for example
[Music]
can you give an example of a something
like that i feel like i
i'm having trouble understanding um
so uh uh
i mean particularly when safety is
involved for example i think it's very
hard to do
you know do design using data
you need something in the in real time
to ensure that
safety constraints or things like that
are met for example
icse um
that seems hard um
let me uh let me offer maybe a slightly
controversial response though
uh i think that right now the
conventional way of thinking about
safety is that safety is external to a
learning process
i think that in the long run at least in
robotics but probably many other domains
data-driven methods will be superior in
terms of safety
because if you are if your safety
mechanisms and your constraints are
external to the learning process they
have to be informed by human
ingenuity if they are informed by data
they can
likely cover more special cases and more
exceptions than the best
human engineer could i think the trouble
is that we just haven't figured out
quite the right learning techniques for
i think in the long run data-driven
safety
data-driven robustness and safety
methods will actually turn out to be
superior
to the approach of manually enumerating
constraints and then forcing those
constraints onto the learning process
but i'll admit that's a controversial
opinion i you know
i'm doing some work on that i could
probably try to defend it but i
definitely don't expect everyone to
agree with me on that
i definitely think that the sort of
start that the fact that rl has been
starting to think a lot more about
safety and ai and learning from the
control community is a really exciting
topic
to be considered for a lot of the
methods to be applicable to sort of more
high-stakes domains
um and whether that sort of relies on
smoothness assumptions or
or human design constraints or if it if
there's sort of tolerable amounts of
exploration so that it can be more
data-driven
i think there's a lot of really
interesting questions in that space for
both of your
comments
wonderful well thank everybody so uh
thanks everyone so much for
participating i'll leave it to my other
two
co-organizers if they'd like to say
anything else
just just farewell and thank you it's
been uh it's been
really uh what's been a cool week and
great discussion today
so thank you all and i think a big
a big thank you to the organizers are
also in order uh for
for organizing this wonderful workshop
yes thank you so much
thank you thanks everybody
thanks everyone bye thank you